can you use kitchen scissors to cut my
hair at home absolutely of course you
can short answer is no I did my first
haircut using kitchen scissors I kitchen
scissors are the go-to hey guys my name
is Mark Bustos I'm bachelier my name is
Miguel also knows the normal father my
name is Maddie Conrad hey everyone my
name is Verna Scott I'm here to add to
some frequently asked questions take 300
what are the basic tools I need to cut
my hair at home what are the basic tools
I need to cut my hair at home I would
keep it simple less is more essentially
you only need five things to be able to
do a half decent haircut at home you
need to sharpen up a pair of scissors
that will cut hair clippers with
thoughts maybe just a beard trimmer comb
is gonna help you get old a little bit
you might miss otherwise and a towel or
a cape or I mean if you're really hard
up you can use a bedsheet that's a lot
just can't you use a beard trimmer to
clean up your hair can you use a beard
trimmer to clean up your here the answer
is yes you can use a beater
not to do a full haircut I personally
would stick to around the ears and with
the beard trimmer you usually cannot
adjust that blade so it comes sent out
of the box as tight as it can get which
means if you push too hard then you'll
probably feel it so you don't want to do
that especially coming around the ears
right around right where your your your
starts right in the corner that spot
right there is very easy to cut I mean
you literally top that part you're gonna
open yourself up so you want to be very
careful especially going around the ears
what Clippers should I buy and where
should I get it from
what Clippers should I buy and where do
I get them so my two favorite Clippers
to use are the wall senior Corvis and
the wall magiclip for this I suggest
going for something that has an
adjustable lever this is going to give
you more control over the length and is
ultimately going to be a much better
clipper for cutting hair at home
I've been sitting my clients to buy the
clipper and I liked it because it looked
like an old Sony Walkman the best thing
you want to do is spend a little bit
more you get a mafia money be last a lot
longer a good pair of clippers is
probably gonna cost you anywhere between
fifty and one hundred and twenty-five
dollars for at-home use there's no need
to spend over 150 bucks for clipper so
this is 40 bones I think this is the
perfect one I use it as a professional
and it'll set you back maybe 80 to 90
bucks comes with a cape comes with a
comb comes with a scissor and it comes
with the attachments personally I think
that people should go to their local
pharmacy write whatever they always have
your trimmers they have hair clippers
and I would go with wall because that
they've been around for years or more
how you use kitchen scissors to cut my
hair at home absolutely of course you
can short answer is no it's my first
haircut using kitchen scissors I kitchen
scissors are the go-to if you don't have
anything else and what you want to do is
you just want to grab a piece and test
it hold on I'll do it I'll do it
hold on you grab a piece and you just
test it and if they cut your in hair is
actually very hard to cut and
hairdressing scissors are incredibly
sharp
they're almost like two crossing razor
blades see how sharp they were they run
straight through the head you don't want
your hair to pull because one that it's
gonna hurt and two you're not gonna get
an even time then just put a fold and
you see that it's just pull in the head
if you're creative you can use anything
to
anything done some of the other things
that you might find in your arsenal is a
gardening shear which I tried and have
no luck
can you yes shoot you okay think it's to
cut metal with I don't know but this
thing works killer it's not good with
professional Cheers but if they cut they
cut I don't even know what you would
call this should I use a bowl to cut my
hair
should I use a bowl to cut my hair well
I think that really depends on the
outcome you're hoping for you should
never have a I I just don't get it
absolutely just go with it you know
course you ever ever the only two times
it's okay to use a boulder to cut your
hair is either in high fashion or if
your mother does it for you with kitchen
shears when you're five ever trying you
the ball yeah it's not suggested how do
I set up my mirrors to cut my hair how
do I set up my mirrors to cut my own
hair however you can rig it to where you
can see the back because you're gonna
need your hands-free small mirror
nothing fancy and rather than looking
into the big mirror and using the small
mirror to see the back you just want to
turn yourself around and look into the
small beer and have a big mirror behind
you you might want to try using the face
camera on your iPhone there may be a lag
and in some cases it's gonna be a
reverse field of view so it might take
just a little adjustment to figure out
if I move my hand left is it gonna go
left or is it gonna go right you're
gonna have to go through trial and error
and the best way to learn things is to
make mistakes
can I use hydrogen peroxide or lemon
juice to light in my hair technically
yes I've tried it as a kid it you know
it lifts it a little bit but it usually
doesn't lift it enough to leave it out a
good color you know during times like
this we might want to kind of try
different things and experiment and try
to color our hair with kind of DIY
things at home it's really not advisable
to do that especially if you've had your
hair previously colored not only could
you thought in your head you could thumb
with your skin as well leave hair
coloring to the profession in reality
one when all this is said and done iam
to get back to the salon it's actually
gonna cost you more money to fix that
hair color that it was to just get it
done in the first place without looking
crazy how do you grow your hair um
one answer to that is invest in a good
hat I use pomade this is a great styling
tool to slick your hair and it actually
makes your hair look less big one of the
things that most people struggle with is
using the same products that they had
for their short hair on their now longer
hair you want to transition into
something that would be more of a paste
or a grooming cream something it's gonna
be a little softer and let the hair move
and look naturally separated goes longer
yukon without getting it cooked grow
your hair long and grace the crazy
well now it's shaggy it's wild most
favorite trick I use at home a steamer
so a steamer is a really great way to
actually get rid of all the bad head and
here you do have super thick hair it's
coarse and straight I would definitely
put in some coconut oil after you
shampoo it then does get the steam on
the areas that are not how I want them
too little bit to kind of like lay it
down
tone it down so it's not like crazy in a
bad way
Erica you could already see I've had
this theme on my head for about 15
seconds already kind of just back to its
natural state do you have to wash your
hair everyday no thick hair absolutely
not you do not want to wash it every day
I like a little bit like days of dirt
but with really fine hair or really thin
hair that needs to be washed every day
for sure do I have to wash my hair every
day I used to wash my hair every day cuz
I used to wake open I used to feel DC
but eventually I got to the point where
I thought to me there and now any
washing you have maybe twice a week the
problem is is that the more you wash it
the oilier your hair will get because
your scalp is trying so hard to produce
oil to condition your hair I find a
thousand of a Bethan eventually when you
stop washing it so much it stops
creating as much oil and you can rinse
it out with one water really well and
that'll be the trick how do I support my
barber all I'm stuck at home I think
that the way to support your barber is
to suggest you know can I prepay for a
few haircuts
can I need to give certificates some
demo tips and they can you can recoup
that later just to reach out to your
barber and ask them for their advice
because you know barbers and stylist
wanna know and want to feel like they
can help somebody because that's what we
do for a living is we help people and we
make people look and feel good and the
fact that we're home right now stuck for
a month or two not being able to do our
job is very difficult for us there are a
lot of legitimate
then lit funds that are set up to help
barbers a lot of smaller barbershops and
even bigger shops are doing Bobby's here
we're starting a project called support
your local barber where you can go and
visit our website at WWE barber comm
where you can learn more about how we're
supporting local barbers and helping
them stay at home and still earn a
living just you know share that GoFundMe
check us on your social media feeds and
say how much you miss us because they're
just gonna make us feel a little better
about ourselves you guys thanks for
having me I hope that we entered some
being eight I hope we answered some of
your questions you know just stay safe
stay healthy and your barber misses you
I miss all of you and I'm sure you miss
us too yeah let's all get through this
together let's brawl everyone stay safe
and check on the people that you love
and don't forget it's just hair piece